so today we're talking about battlefield
2042 getting hit with a delay how you
can finally connect bluetooth headphones
to your switch and how the developers of
split gate are just swimming in a pool
full of money my name is devonte
chisholm and you're watching gamespot
news originally slated for release on
october 22nd battlefield 2042 will now
arrive on november 19th ea said the
teams did not have the opportunity to
get back together in person to work on
finishing the game and that this meant
extra time was needed before it would be
ready the game is now releasing very
close to halo infinite though it's now
coming a few weeks after call of duty
vanguard instead of right before it so
far it's already been a long road to
release for battlefield 2042 as dice
took an extra year with the game to give
developers more time to make the most of
the ps5 and xbox series x and s the game
supports 128 players on those platforms
compared to the 64 on ps4 and xbox one
and now let's talk about nintendo late
last night switch owners got a big
surprise when it was announced that
bluetooth audio output was finally added
in a new firmware update a feature that
many fans have been requesting since the
console's launch and i want to stress
the word output because bluetooth
microphones are not supported and
additionally bluetooth audio won't work
when the switch's local wireless
connection is running some other changes
included in the update are the ability
to stay connected to the internet in
sleep mode when using a wired connection
a new way to start the control stick
calibration process and the ability to
connect up to two wireless controllers
when using bluetooth better late than
never i guess but i do feel kind of bad
for the people who bought the third
party piece to make the bluetooth
possible even though that does have less
limitations than the official update so
i guess it wasn't a waste of money
yesterday the developer of the popular
halo meets portal multiplayer shooter
split gate announced it has raised 100
million dollars in funding to help
support its ambitions let me say that
again
100 million dollars in a statement ceo
ian prow said quote i'm happy to confirm
that we are not selling our company to
one of the big guys instead 1047 games
will stay independent and continue to be
a quote community first game developer
the 100 million dollars in funding will
help 1047 games hire a lot more
developers and this in turn will help
the team deliver more and better updates
to split gate this will also help the
studio fix bugs faster and support a
wider base of players overall 1047 games
is now valued at 1.5 billion according
to games industry.biz
and in some gaming related news mcu star
anthony mackie is set to play the lead
character john doe in an upcoming tv
series based on twisted metal as
announced previously deadpool writers
rhett reese and paul wernick came up
with the idea for the show and cobra
kai's michael jonathan smith is writing
according to deadline the producers at
sony pictures tv and playstations
productions are quote extremely high on
the show and will begin to shop it
around to network soon deadline also has
the details on the tv show's story it
will follow mackie who is a quote
motor mouth outsider offered a chance at
a better life but only if he can
successfully deliver a mysterious
package across a post-apocalyptic
wasteland
in the comment section let me know on a
scale of 1 to 10 how bummed you are
about the battlefield delay
and hopefully we don't get another game
delay in tomorrow's video
peace
[Music]
you